so hi and thank you very much for
inviting me here
Alexander so actually I would you say
gets to eat to touch up on three topics
so high performance computing I'm heavy
AI so for us I think that we see as an
HPC and I quote from being an HPC so in
my title is technical consulting
engineer whatever you so basically I
talk to the core engineering folks who
designed the libraries and everything
that introduces and the people who uses
so I'm the limpid in the end users and
the engineers panel is background into
the cells from ribbon and neck listening
so with my case study I will introduce
you a problem and how is AI to solve
this problem but then we have a look at
the deep learning algorithm that we have
designed to solve this problem and the
various frameworks involved and how we
gain the best performance so let's start
with some statistics so why this
research that I'm going to present to
you it's actually
why it is so important first some
numbers in 2018 they were close to 18
million people who had cancer and out of
this boot not 50 % 46 million people
dying so that's quite considerable and
the power of my research is brain Truman
finding so how can we use a I to find
brain tumors in people so the medical
tape that we use for regiments climbers
and climbers actually the most dangerous
types of cancers that we can I mean to
have it it's written back and close to
90% of this glamorize they belong to
highly receive classes of cancer
treatment so it's really important to
diagnose them and once you progress or
hobbies it's crucial to resolve this and
to date and our ISO magnetic resonance
imaging is the primary method to screen
and diagnose all lifelines and once you
have gone into this MRI machine will
create a 3d image of your brain and that
the doctor will have to analyze this and
in order to do that the doctor will have
to segment the 3d volume update that MRI
image and analyze all of that slice by
slice and why segmentation is important
for the two ways that you can actually
fix the treatment area so there are two
ways one is when you coffee or in
therapy when you actually use these
Kansai area cancer cells shelter them
with laser or if it's like really really
bad then you may need to engage a doctor
and the researcher eight open the
braiding them extract the blood cells so
in order to do that we analyze life
specialized and pretty rudimentary I'm
alright scan and the medical change
involved in all of this is that first
where people have enough regular gypsum
and also the segmentation process is
very time-consuming expensive however we
believe that of us can help and this is
where it is convenient by honing in the
compute power and the technologies that
we have right now in the eye we can
hopefully solve this challenge of you
know and on top of that if you like look
at this loss of nearly hundred
fifty-three exabytes of health care data
so that in the medical sector so much
data was collected and that's only in
2013 and I searched endlessly for data
for two thousand eighty and ninety
aquaeden but we know that this that
almost one hundred fifty-three would
reach to over 2,000 by 2020 and now you
may ask well what is an exabyte when so
1x a life is 1 billion gigabytes or 250
mm of these guys that's a lot so we have
a lovely as a big data and it's not time
for computer
crunch all this data and give us good
reasons right so in my research I have
used an open data set from the challenge
images labeled data and my goal was in
training neural network to find cancer
so there are degrees so have an issue or
differences in learning
okay talking about these terms but four
categories essentially at the end of the
day one remember that there is canceled
in cancer right in that 3d model one
item one element is called a box a box
that looks like that it's like let me
zoom on that guy you can get it in your
network will be able to do that for us
instead of having a doctor look at that
slice and do that so the reason that's
my summary slide of what I did the
number I put was what the Machine gave
us that's constants
and that middle part is what a real
doctor
[Music]
label the can serve areas under a
meringue and that's what he called the
ground I use these two I feel it into my
arrow Network I trained it so that when
a new MRI becomes a new slice
to predict the conservative so that's an
example here with an accuracy of a
50-person it did quite well the neural
network there's a white paper on it
saying that one of its small and 72%
it's already very good and might be 82
person okay so a little bit deep deep
your own an oil that I use in my rhythm
it's called
[Music]
and this process extracts features from
the input image it will slice up 15 feet
and at the end of the day what we are
going to get is cancer colon cancer from
it birds I took my whole algorithm would
like this we are taking data set labeled
images so cancer and all right good and
then the labels whether it's cancer we
feed it into the bureau network we do
the training that is some time and then
once the training is done we have the
Train model then the job is kind of done
and then we have you patients coming in
from the testing then induce
train order and then the process of
predicting all the tech computer science
that is influencing so we do anything
and then we get the results that's it so
that's what we did and you may also be
curious to know what software we use to
make this happen
so that is somebody when there is
software
so of course the entire distribution for
item for best performance and by the way
my ball told all of it is that invited
so this is to say that in fact you can
do a lot of things that you know that I
use tensorflow and on top carrots to
make life easy and then over work
however is a technology developed back
in well you know the car company
surprise involving what is a technology
that allows you to split this heavy
compute intensive training process onto
multiple machines so this is for
distributed training in France in
constant so this is these are the
principles involved and let's have a
look at the language so when I did this
training process on running one machine
20 impose in time Xeon processor 20
impose in terms of flow from
mumu they took 76 our borders to create
my whole dataset that's a lot of time
and I was not very pleased with 26 so if
this is always and I thought okay what
can we do first use optimized and said
look so this is what interest an
interest ik and that support from Google
has platinum performance mathematical
library Monday and that we did much
better and this is represented by the
second bar there I dropped from seventy
six hours to for referring others within
the optimal stencil
machine and I was still unhappy before
plus others I said can I do better of
course and the idea is to scale so then
I went from one machine to no machine so
by scaling with problem for instance
that's one before the last I use four
machines and eight with a so forth from
one level to follows I drove it from 40
hours to 7.5 hours and then doubling the
number of workers I found that he takes
from seven hours to 5.5 hours and the
key part here is optimized software so
if you look at the first and the second
it's just a change in software from non
of the mass density my friends of the
same machine bobbin didn't change I hope
from 76 hours to 43 hours that is now
also playing reading all of the software
together including the provenance
library a software stack look at this so
on top I have my work my and work my
research and then the software used and
the corrals underwater video all of this
way much faster with Intel math kernal
library or Vampira in Vienna so the
event sent will give you one network and
that's the tiny person
a library that makes itself compute
involved in a value much faster and I've
carried such follow me to build an
assembly in not intensive tasks and
scalable on which people have a big fat
processes BG so scale on this guy's back
to the training really fast and I'm
curious to see how this will affect the
slices look in a at the end of the day I
will show you this this is how it looks
like in 3d so every stress step step
together and that's how the doctor would
see it in this 3d model oh yeah that's
it if you found this interesting and you
would like to play with it the source
code is open to providing for free and
as we speak there are two research
institutes in germany and one of which
in the hospital for our taken distant
source code and adapted for their real
patient
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is there any chance to get the library's
also running on the CPU yeah
so I want performance libraries or how
we're aiming architecture at your house
dispatcher nobody if you have friends as
a call or checks what architecture okay
[Music]
thank you
I think you can ask them further
questions
[Applause]